let's try the same kind of strategy we
did before and see how it fares it gives
the question like this okay the first
thing we tried was to collect like terms
right and we didn't just collect them
anywhere we wanted to collect the
letters the pearly rules we wanted to
collect them on the left-hand side okay
so that means you've got to get rid of
them all off the right-hand side and
before I took away 5x obviously taking
away 5x here it's not gonna be very
helpful because they're to exit anyway
but also there aren't five of them there
are nine of them right so on this side
I'm gonna say 9r minus three by this
night I'm gonna get rid of all of the
odds on this side if I take away 9r from
one side I've got to take away from the
other okay so this is what I've got
okay now so far so good this looks a lot
like this line but then what unfolds is
a little bit different watch let's have
a look at what happens here I'm gonna
collect like terms I've got eyes here
I'll circle them said it's clear I've
got three are here but I've got watch
for the sign I've got minus nine are
there right so I have to take away nine
you don't add them right so what's 3
minus 9 3 minus 9 is yeah it's gonna go
- 9 he's gonna go way past 0 over 2
minus 6 they do see obsession soon so
there you go that's how many R's I have
on that side which is slightly weird but
that's what happened
well that was that plus 13 it just it
just stays there we haven't done
anything to it there are no terms - I'm
collect them outside over here the odds
all disappear that's why I subtracted 9
r wasn't it so all I get is negative 3
all right now we're getting there
that's okay there are lots of different
ways but remember so wait I'm better
than others I will have a look at in a
second yeah now at this point what do I
do
well I want to simplify don't I okay in
a similar way as I did the previous step
I'll get all these thirteenth out of the
way right so I'll put that over to the
side so I'm going to minus 30 from both
sides
and that's what I get there okay
so over the left-hand side the 13
disappears the plus the blinks kids'll
out minus 3 minus 13 that's negative 16
isn't it like you you got your zero
there's [ __ ] treat you don't even
further that way okay so that's my
finger of success okay now at this point
and our previous question we were
finished but we're not finished yet
are we okay what do I have to do to this
view I just want the R by itself I this
here might might is 6r it's really
shorthand for - six times R isn't it so
being that it's it's multiplication I
want to undo that right so what's the
how do I undo multiplication division
right so I have to divide I've got to
divide by whatever I'm multiplying by
that's negative 6 right so if I defined
the left here it's had binary six we're
gonna divide the right hand side by
negative six
okay what's gonna happen on the left
hand side the negative sixes and cancel
just get off one time that's good what
happens over here okay so the negatives
right the negatives are gonna cancel
right so I'm not gonna have a are the
negatives going to disappear so then I
have 16 over six can I simplify that yes
I can write what should i divide through
by I could divide this by 4 but not this
one I think it's just - I think it's
just - 8 over 3
I suppose if we wanted to we could turn
it into a mixed numeral which i think is
2 into thirds
okay so you can yeah that's bleep so
what happened this is you see what I
mean by it isn't one snip your credit or
two step equation it's a lots of steps
equations right and in the same way like
some of these steps I could have done
quick up right see how I moved all the
odds over this side and then I've moved
all the numbers over this side you can
sort of do them both at once if you feel
confident it's much faster right but
we've done it that we showed all of the
steps and that's where our answer is
okay just like before we're into this
mode but just like before you can stick
this back into the first line and it'll
work okay so we still did the collecting
like terms we did a bit of simplifying
we have to do extra simplify because the
numbers they gave us or a bit gross but
we still got out the answer in just the
same way the acid test is can you
explain to someone else no no no I got
anybody your time today